hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to well I was
right
it'll never be
I just got that song out of my head and
it's back it's free get back in February
2015 it was announced Disney was
rebooting one of the most beloved
classic shows ducktales first people
didn't know what to think of it reboots
were everywhere and overdone but at the
same time its ducktales it seems like
there's possibilities for it then the
premiere of the intro was put on YouTube
and it was actually pretty damn good
it makes modern animation with the
classic Disney comic book style of the
50s it was both a great update as well
as a great throwback and then they did
something even cooler they released the
first episode on YouTube yeah you can go
to Disney XD's YouTube and watch the
premiere right now oh good I didn't want
have to borrow someone's Disney Go
password I guess they're that confident
that you'll like it and keep coming back
for more as you probably notice we've
talked about ducktales several times on
this show so it only makes sense to see
if they were right is it as good as
they're hyping it up to be and will we
come back for more let's find out by
taking a look at the first episode of
the ducktales reboot it opens with a
seagull flying through the air and a
bunch of feathered sailors shooing it
away they're all birds how does this
work what is who don't get a lot doofy
it's never explained we see some ducks
on the water though as a boat house
containing Donald Duck and his nephews
Huey Dewey and Louie
good morning uncle Donald you can't wear
this to your job interview who are
presumably now little people in their
twenties try to get Donald to his job
interview so they can take the boat out
and get into trouble did he just call
her a crazy old broad someone's been
talking to the cop from grandma got run
over by a reindeer baby can't looking
for the old brat I'll just put the enjoy
counter over there and pray there's a
tailspin reboot Oh maybe you like action
one Donald realizes he can't leave them
alone it decides to take them to uncle
Scrooge's house you were supposed to get
him out by 10 o'clock Hubert you were
supposed to signal before you started
the boat Duford we never get to do
anything Lewbert
with business expanding in the spoon
Orville and st. canard
it's yeah now that I hear that trust me
there's a lot of them
Scrooge finds the color has literally
gone out of his life as he doesn't
really go on adventures anymore he just
mostly sits around and talked with his
business executives a group of vultures
you know I'm only three minutes into the
show and already it's more insanely
clever that needs to be fantastic
Scrooge is voiced by David Tennant which
is very fitting seeing how he's so
cranky you could see him instructing
someone to throw coffee in their own
face Donald and Scrooge don't really get
along but Donald does manage to trick
him into looking after the boys for just
a few hours and yes by the way those
apples have diamonds in them really
think about the number of questions that
raises Scrooge throw us in their room
with a bag of marbles and orders has
made mrs. Beakley to not let them
interfere with anything a gift from your
great uncle you will return them upon
your departure he's counted them okay to
be fair marbles were like the Batarang
in the original you can do a lot with
them so we're totally ditching this room
right yes see they're already getting
some my ceiling you know damn it shows
stop being so clever they escaped but
are immediately captured by B Cleese
granddaughter wait'll the I mean okay so
well she does seem eerily similar to
gravity falls most popular character
there certainly are some differences one
she has no friends where a Mabel was a
social butterfly are we friends now if
we say yes will you let us live best
friend
- well she's excitable she's also
socially awkward into be being overly
protective and three she is kind of a
violent edge who sent you my beagle
bungled answer me and to be fair most
people would rather have a variation of
Mabel than a variation of the original
Webby apparently the writers thought the
same thing is there's an arrow in a doll
of her past designed too soon her her
while you're at it
Scrooge feels down about the kids
calling him a has-been though so he
plans to go on an expedition to find
Atlantis I'm no husband I am
now a shift in currents may present a
pathway to Atlantis just we didn't
already search once with Disney it got
mixed results webby takes them to the
wing of Secrets I told you one cabinet
where they start to wonder if Scrooge as
well as Donald actually when on all the
adventures they claim to go on it's good
to know that Roxanne is still getting
job interviews after breaking up with
max he did not sure you doubt by the way
he's dating some model a butt-ugly CGI
model they accidentally open a chest
releasing the ghost of Captain peg hook
and his T the headless man horse I'm
just gonna pretend I'm gonna sleep well
tonight he says he won't leave until he
gets the head of Scrooge
so Scrooge obliges by giving him the
head from one of his statues
bars
okay it's funny as that is we never see
that horse again if there's any
character I want to know what happened
to but they release another ancient evil
a giant Chinese dragon and much like the
live-action reboot of Mulan it's only
there to consume riches so it chases
after Scrooge's gold ticket Scrooge's
limo driver Launchpad to pilot the plane
to stop them they use the Medusa
gauntlet to turn him into stone and
presumably murder him need to be fair
they do show not having a head is in the
robe locket used to be Scrooge's
impressed with their adventure making
shenanigans and he wants them to join
him and his search for Atlantis but in a
hilarious twist the job Donald was
applying for belongs to Scrooge's mortal
enemy glum goals the second richest duck
in the world welcomed new employees took
Lum gold in those two days well now we
know what the CEO of Tilted Kilt looks
like
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so one gold wants to go after Atlantis
to become the richest duck in the world
and he's hired a team of assassins to
get it before Scrooge it's weird enough
seeing Donald with modern day technology
but do his feathers have fingerprints to
swipe shows asking so many questions I
never thought I would ask
so Scrooge in the game make it to
Atlantis and find it's all upside down
the Atlanteans were so eager to build an
epic city of wonders and death traps
they didn't stop to figure I had a
proper support structure and the whole
thing fell into the sea so they made
that sign after the city sank he must
have died while carving it do we wants
to experience as much adventure as
possible but he finds being upside down
sucks a lot of the action out of it but
Donald tries to save Dewey from himself
bring us all together in the back seat
while you drive oh come on
nobody lumps you all together blue one
that actually is another cool element of
the show they tried to have Huey Dewey
and Louie have a little bit more
identity so you can tell them a little
bit more apart I can even think of the
last time I saw an episode of anything
where one gets individual focus as
opposed to all of them sharing the same
amount of time that's fond remembering
but ghulam goal gets the jewel first and
finds out Donald is related to them and
leaves them to drown
they're ducks they can float stop
screwed she was trying to keep me out of
trouble but I was so caught up and why
is there a lamp on the floor hey come on
you interrupted the Disney lesson we had
like 20 more seconds of synth music
that's the real jewel of Atlanta
something lit up when the trap was
sprung I'd bet my bottom dollar it's the
power source but runs the city and they
said we never used those scripts from a
TV show that never happened
meanwhile um Gold's henchmen seem to
really suck at what they do as glum gold
tries to blow Atlantis up with everybody
inside mr. duck maybe bum a ride with
you we're just gonna be confused for
Ninja Turtle villains if we don't get
more screen time they of course help
them out and show up glum gold with the
real treasure mr. McDuck how do you
respond to claims how Roxanne got
another job pretty quick applying for
henchwoman and ending up as a TV
reporter life's funny that way so
through lame excuses not really needed
to justify kids going on adventures kids
some caregivers just be bad people it's
agreed that the boys can stay with
Scrooge especially after their houseboat
blows up I may have left the engine
running in the houseboat the circle is
now complete
reclusive adventure capitalist scrooge
mcduck is back solving mysteries and
rewriting history chit chit chat
Chippendales rescue right oh I had it so
doughy is happy to know that his family
is so adventurous and that he truly
belongs
I'll just celebrate this incredibly
serviceable ending by drinking out of my
favorite and most expensive champagne
glass with my favorite and most
expensive champagne inside as I will do
now
[Music]
now do you know how close I was to
dropping that mom as in parents you're
we doing Louie have parents has that
ever been addressed in a cartoon
whenever I just assumed they were clones
spawned in a laboratory of comedic
sidekicks we're actually gonna do this
it's finally gonna be explained who huey
dewey and louie's parents are ducktales
this reboot is everything you would want
it to be it's funny it's creative it's
modern its retro its classic its new it
has great animation with charming
characters it's clearly combining
old-school Disney adventures like their
comics and the Disney Afternoon with
newer Disney adventures like Star versus
the forces of evil and gravity falls and
they mix perfectly I know it's only a
first episode but it's made me an
immediate fan going from slightly
curious to incredibly intrigued I can't
wait to see where this goes how they
represent old characters and how they
introduce new characters if you want to
see how to do a reboot right go over the
Disney XD's YouTube right now and watch
ducktales woo friggin whoo
[Music]
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys dog walker here doing the
charity shout on this week we have a
very special charity shout out one of
our producers Tiger who does mu D - mm
oh he's doing this super long bike ride
to raise awareness of pancreatic cancer
Action Network
this is a charity that he very much
stands behind he lost both his parents
to pancreatic cancer and he's doing this
super long bike ride to raise awareness
of it and you can hear me talk about but
why when he can tell you himself here's
a video explaining what he's doing why
he's doing it and why you should
definitely donate
[Music]
in the last video I said that me in the
tank were going places and we are I've
been doing quite a few overnighters like
this one that you're watching right now
prepare for what's gonna be quite the
epic journey I'm gonna be taking an
Amtrak out to Seattle Washington and
I'll be embarking on a bike ride on
August 4th 2017 I'm gonna follow a
routes been blazed by the Adventure
Cycling Association and this is the
current plan map I'll be taking that
several of their routes linked together
and I'm gonna be visiting Washington
Idaho Montana North Dakota Minnesota
before finally getting back to my home
near Milwaukee Wisconsin and at this
point you might be wondering well why
I'm doing this as an awareness and
fundraising effort for the Pancreatic
Cancer Action Network I've lost both of
my parents to pancreatic cancer my mom
in 2002 my dad in 2016 and in both cases
the doctors and medical staff did
everything that they could but the truth
is there really isn't much they
currently can do the last time I saw my
dad he was really sick and he had asked
me what I plan on doing the bike riding
stuff because he knew what I was really
getting into it
and I showed him pictures from my
October overnighter and I showed him
this map and I had this crazy idea of
riding cross-country and he wished me
luck
he wished me well and then he hope that
I could make it in two days later he was
gone and that's when the trip became
more than just a romp across America
pancreatic cancer is one of the most
aggressive kinds it's the only cancer
there's a five-year relative survival
rate in the single digits nine percent
there's currently no early detection
method for pancreatic cancer and most
people only find out they have it in the
late stages when it's already spread
through the body chemotherapy and other
traditional methods of treatment are
just not working so what we need are
research and clinical trials and I'm not
a doctor I'm not a researcher but I want
to do something to help fight this so
what I can do is I can help raise money
for the fund much-needed research and it
might find a cure someday pancreatic
cancer action network they fund research
and other programs in the hope that
someday pancreatic cancer is just a bad
memory and nothing more
[Music]
so if you want to support the ride you
can do several things under this video
you're going to see a fundraising page
for the Pancreatic Cancer Action Network
and if you click on that you can donate
directly there
my goal is $5,000 but I would love to
double that second please share that
link and encourage other people to
donate as well and third I'm inviting
you along for the ride even if it's just
virtually speaking I might be on the
road solo I can't do this one alone I'm
gonna have a satellite tracking unit on
my bike so you'll be able to follow my
progress on the webpage river otter
cycling dot club / track you'll also be
able to find a banner there with a link
to the pan kin fundraising site and
that'll be up in late July I'm also
planning out having live video streams
either on periscope or Facebook as
reception permits
I'm fully anticipating being out of cell
range on several places so I don't have
a set schedule for these other than I'm
going to try to broadcast between 4 & 7
p.m. local time whenever I can and if
you live along the route if you have to
I'll give you a great way to contact me
and you want to join me for a couple
miles on a day that's fantastic it'll be
great to meet some people raise
awareness and maybe even raise some
money for pancreatic cancer research
together I think we can start to make a
difference and I think we can all wage
hope on pancreatic cancer
[Music]
you